right so homework - you guys are priced
starting to work on and we're having
sessions this week that are good for if
you don't have background and deep
learning and feel free to reach out and
be how's that oh yeah questions great
one yeah visit the post on Piazza you're
always welcome to design your own
project that's always completely fine
and a number of you have come talk to me
about those or talk to other days these
are an additional options so if people
are interested in looking at either the
default project which we released
yesterday which is to do with bandits
warfarin or if you want to look at some
of the suggestions from senior PhD
students or postdocs those are great
opportunities particularly I think if
you haven't ever done reinforcement
learning before it's often I wouldn't
expect it three weeks in that you'd be
able to defy the state of the art
project um so if you're interested in
learning more about we RL research then
it can be a really great opportunity to
look at some of those suggested projects
then reach out to people the other thing
that I just wanted to do a friendly
reminder about is we explicitly post FA
cues for each of the homeworks and some
of the CAS are mentioning that some of
the students coming into office hours
right now might not have had a chance to
look at those so if you're if you're
ever questioned when you're going with
homework the first thing to do is to go
to Piazza and particularly to look at
those pin notes at the very top which
have F a very common FA cues about the
assignment so make sure to read those
before you go to office hours and then
of course feel free to come to office
hours as well but those are a really
good resource to look at any other
questions alright so just in terms of
where we are in the course right now we
went through DQ n on Monday we're gonna
talk today some a bit more about I we
can wrap up some of the stuff that I had
to rush through at the end of Monday in
terms of DQ learning and some of the
recent extensions and then we're gonna
talk to some about imitation learning in
large state spaces before next week
starting to talk about policy gradient
methods
so just as we'll start off with a
refresher from what dqn was doing dqn
was this idea of combining between key
learning and using deep neural networks
as function approximator and the two key
sort of algorithmic changes compared to
prior work was that they used experience
replay and fixed cue targets and by
fixed cue targets there that was meaning
that when we used our ARP RT plus gamma
max over a queue of sta st plus 1 that
the weights that were used for that
queue representation were fixed for a
while so maybe we'd update those every
hundred steps or every 50 episodes or
some interval and so this pre hit
provided a more stable target for
supervised learning because as a
supervised learning part again is that
we were had this combination of we want
to have wait sum and we want to minimize
this error versus our current estimate
sort of minimizing the TD error so the
way that this proceeded is that we'd
sort of store transition in a replay
memory buffer we do mini batches we read
sample a batch of state action reward
next state tuples and then do these
backups where we're sort of updating our
q function and refitting our q function
and like a lot of the linear value
function methods we saw before it uses
stochastic gradient descent and the
really cool thing about this is that
they did it on 50 games they use the
same architecture for those 50 games and
the same hyper parameters and they got
human level performance so we talked
quite a lot about that before and then
we sort of briefly talked about three
sort of major extensions to that in the
immediate following years and again
there's been a lot of extensions and a
lot of working deep reinforcement
learning right now but three of them I
were as follows the first was double D
QN and we talked before we got it to
function approximation talking about the
issue with maximization bias
that when you're using the same
representation to pick an action and
estimate the value of that action you
can get into a maximization bias problem
and the way that that's avoided in
double dqn and I wanted to go over this
again because that a couple questions
after class we didn't have much time to
discuss it is what happens is we have a
current queue network which is
parametrized by a set of weights and
that is what is used to select actions
now just to be clear here often we're
doing some sort of a greedy method so
we'd use the current queue network
weights to decide on the best action and
we would pick that with one minus
Epsilon probability and then there is an
older queue network that is used to
evaluate those actions so if we look at
how we're going to be changing our
weights we're gonna be having an action
evaluation using these other weights w-
and then action selection using w so
when you look at this it might start to
look pretty similar to what dqn was
doing because DQ n was saying we're
gonna use a fixed set of weights for for
these target updates so what DQ n was
doing was this R plus gamma Q I'll write
the max in hey W minus is the current so
in the normal DQ n they were also using
a W minus but here in a double DQ n it
can be a little bit different and the
reason it's a little bit different than
what we just saw is that you can
maintain two sets of weights at all
times and you can flip between them on
every step or every batch so when DQ n
was introduced it was more of an idea of
you fix your your weights let's say from
time step T to time step T plus 100 use
the same weights that whole time period
for your target in double D Q and you
don't necessarily have to do that you
can flip back and forth between these
which is what we'd seen with a double
q-learning that on the you know on step
one you could use weights one to act and
weights two to evaluate on step two you
can do weights two to evaluate weights
one to act so it means that you can
propagate information faster so instead
of waiting fifty episodes or 100
episodes to update the weights that
you're using for your target so again
this is your target you couldn't flip
back and forth between them which allows
you to update both networks a lot power
up by both incentive network weights
their networks are identical yeah in
general when you're evaluating these
kinds of different approaches to improve
these techniques is there there's good
trade-off between how fast the
information propagates and then how
unstable it is so we might find that if
the the system we're trying to learn on
is itself relatively well-behaved and
stable we want to pick something that
has faster information propagation but
if it's highly noisy or unstable that we
need to do something that's more
conservative make you say Berkshire
which is you know is there generally a
trade-off in terms of these methods
between sort of characterizing the
stability of the system and then how
fast you can propagate information back
unfortunately I feel like it's not very
well characterized so I feel like we're
most the time these are heuristics and
people evaluate them and they evaluate
them a lot of different benchmarks and
that's sort of the way we get
generalization but I don't think that
there's a good characterization
systemically of how to characterize the
stability of the system with these deep
neural networks particularly the context
of RL so there's a lot of great
opportunities for theoretical analysis
here too or just sort of more formal
understanding right now I think we're at
the level of saying does either just
seems to consistently work a bunch of
across Atari games and maybe mojo co or
it doesn't and try to characterize and
said the successes yeah yeah so question
is about you know how could we switch
between these W and W - and how would
you you know why and how would you do
this so in the dqn setting you could set
W - so at the beginning W - is equal to
W on time step zero and then in DQ and
you would keep W mine
to be the same maybe for the next 50
episodes but you'd be updating W and
then 50 episodes in you would update W -
the downside about that which we talked
a little bit about before is that you're
not using the information you're getting
to update this estimate because you're
using that old stale set of w's so
essentially you're just not using the
information you've got over those 50
episodes to update what would happen if
you result in s Prime and took action a
so an alternative would be to flip
between let's say you instead of
thinking this is w w - that you can
think of it that way you can just think
of maintaining two different sets of
weights and imagine I'll say this is
teak over time because one time it goes
to tenkasi so imagine that we're just
picking between what are the weights
that we use to select an action and that
weights that we use to evaluate the
action so on the first time step you
could use this to evaluate and this to
the to select the action and then you
could flip it back and forth so that
essentially means that both sets of
weights are getting updated very
frequently so instead of updating only
one of the one of them every 50 episodes
you're continuing to propagate that
information by quickly and there's of
course tons of chart choices here about
how frequently do you update you know
when do you switch back and forth
between these and you can think of all
of those as hyper parameters you can
imagine tuning but this is instead of
keeping that keeping this target fixed
for 50 steps or you know n steps these
are all parameters you could flip back
and forth between them which is what
double Q learning did valuation still be
another Q network from TT QN except for
the fact that there's a bit more often
it is almost how different is this from
the previous year it's almost identical
so I think the the main difference here
is that you could switch it as long as
you're maintaining some set of weights
for your target this is saying you could
sort of suite now you really just have
your the same network two sets of
weights that you have to maintain in
memory
and what this is saying is you can
switch back and forth with those right
frequently and help avoid the
maximization bias during that time it
doesn't always work it frequently helps
there is still the issue with stability
that it can be better and it avoids the
maximization bias we also talked about
prioritized experience replay we went
through a small sort of tabular example
where we looked at the impact of doing
backups so if we have this experience
replay buffer of SAR s-prime tuples
which one should we use to do our
backups and how do we propagate that
information back and the in this
algorithm they said there are in this
paper they talked about the fact that if
you can do this optimally in some cases
you might get an exponential speed-up
and convergence but it's hard to do that
it's computationally intensive so what
they proposed here is to prioritize
something based on the size of sort of
the DQ n error the difference between
the current estimate of it and your sort
of target estimate that you're looking
at and so we talked about how you could
use that as a priority and it could be a
stochastic priority to try to select
items and we also talked about the fact
that if you set alpha equal to 0 this
becomes uniform and said then there's no
particular prioritization over your
tuples and then the thing that we had
almost no time to talk about was dueling
so dueling was the best paper I'm from
to 2016 I mean I see him out let me just
give a little bit of refresher on this
because we went through it very very
fast so the the intuition here is that
the features that you might need to
write down the value of a state might be
different than those need to specify the
relative benefit of different actions in
that state and you want to understand
the relative benefit of actions in order
to decide what what your policy should
be so looking at things like game score
it's obviously very relevant the value
that it might be you might want other
features try to decide what actions to
do right now in a game and so the
advantage function that came up that was
designed by Baird a long time ago and
this is the same bears that had that
counter example to show why value
function approximation can be bad so
Baird's work before it said well look
you can decompose you think of your q
function which is representing the value
of a policy 30 and state and taking a
particular action versus the value of
just that state so this is sort of
implicitly q PI s PI s so like what is
the different difference between taking
this particular action versus just
following your policy from the current
state and he called this the advantage
was the advantage of that action for
that state so in dueling DQ n instead of
having one network that just predicts Q
functions they use an architecture that
separates into predicting values and
predicting these Advantage functions and
then adds them back together with the
idea being that you might get different
sort of features here and here so you'd
sort of decouple for a little bit to
make sure that you're capturing the
features that are relevant to capturing
the salient things you want to look at
for Q's now one thing that I mentioned
very briefly last time is that is the is
the advantage function identifiable and
what do I mean by that in this case I
mean that if you have a q function which
is what ultimately we're going to use
can we decompose it into a unique a PI
and B PI so here ultimately we want a q
and the question is if we then are in
architecture decomposing this into a
value and an advantage is there a unique
way to do that is there but there isn't
so if you if you add a constant to both
Q and B then you can get the same
advantage function so there's not a unit
you can always shift your shift your
words by a constant and that's not going
to change your policy will change your
value function I so there's lots of
different ways to decompose your
advantage function and your values it's
not a unique decomposition
the way they defined it there is to say
well let's force the advantage for state
and action to be zero if a is the action
taken so here they compare it to the
action that's taken you're using sort of
say a greedy approach and this is really
just a way to all of this we can think
of it in some ways it's an analogy to
supervised learning and so we want to
have a staple target and we want to be
able to learn these advantage functions
and these value functions if we have
lots and lots of data about them so this
is sort of choosing a particular fixed
point for how to define the advantage
function and then they also said well
empirically you could just use the mean
to so you could just average over here
advantage functions it smart circle here
a stick approach and what they find
again so we sort of were layering up
these additional techniques we started
with DQ n then we thought about adding
double Q learning to DQ n and then we
thought about adding prioritize replay
and then this is dueling and what they
find is that do Liam versus double DQM
with prioritize replay is a lot better
most of the time now let me see if I can
find Montezuma's yep so for Montezuma's
this new method is basically no better
like none of these methods are really
tackling hard exploration problems but
they are doing better ways of sort of
propagating information than Network and
trying to change the way we're training
the network yeah question the back in
name first please okay a little bit
letter can people in the back over there
hear me or is it just depending good
alright so these were three of the
methods that ended up making a big
difference we talked very briefly about
practical tips I won't go on these too
much the main thing is just that we try
to actively encourage you to build up
your acuity representation first before
you try an Atari you can try different
forms of losses learning rate is
important but in this case our
assignment we're gonna be using the atom
optimizer which means you don't have to
worry too much about it
there's a issue of sort of trying
different exploration schemes is
something that we're going to talk about
later in this class so for right now
we're still thinking about just simple
Egret approaches a nice paper that came
out I think it was started 2018 was
rainbow which was the paper that
basically just tried to combine a whole
bunch of these recent methods to see
really how big of an improvement do you
get now again note in this case and
we'll come back to this in just a couple
slides this is a lot of data there's a
lot of experience in the world 200
million frames that experience but they
developed an algorithm called rainbow
that combines a lot of the things we've
just been talking about double DQ n
prioritized and dooli as well as some
other recent advances noisy is one that
also tries to do some different forms of
exploration so they found that kind of
by adding these approvement s-- together
then you could get a significant
improvement I think this is a useful
insight because often it's not clear
whether or not these different gains are
additive or if they're just sort of your
ear they're kind of doing the same thing
but maybe in a slightly different way
and so it's nice to see that in some of
these cases these different sort of
ideas are additive in terms of the
resulting performance game
these aren't sort of this is still a
very large amount of data okay so just
to summarize which are wrapping up where
we are with model free deep neural
networks for RL right now they're very
expressive function approximator z' i
you should be able to understand how you
represent the q function and you can
just watch it carlo based methods or TD
style methods and at this point it's
sort of good to make sure you understand
how you would do that with tabular
methods with linear value function
methods and with deep neural networks so
sort of algorithmically it looks very
similar across all of those but then you
in some cases you have to do this step
of doing function approximation in other
cases you don't and then it would be
good to just make sure you can sort of
list a few extensions that help beyond
dqn and why they do alright so now let's
go back to our sort of high-level view
of what we want from a reinforcement
learning algorithm these algorithms that
are sort of doing optimization handling
generalization doing exploration they're
doing it all statistically and
computationally efficiently and we've
just been spending quite a lot of time
on looking at generalization as well as
optimization we haven't talked very much
about efficiency so one of the
challenges is is that if you want to
define efficiency formally like in terms
of how much data and agent Lee needs to
learn to make a good decision there are
hardness results that that are known so
our lab has developed some lower bounds
other people have to I think we now have
basically tight upper and lower bounds
for the tabular MDB case which indicate
that there's some really pathological MD
peas out there for which we just need a
lot of data on a day that you know would
not scale very well as you start to go
up to really huge domains so some of
these problems are really hard to do
formally you just need a lot of
exploration we can do something much
better than a greedy but we'll talk
about that soon but even when we do
those much better things than a greedy
we can prove that it's still really hard
to learn in those we still might need a
lot of data so an alternative is to say
well there's lots of other supervision
that we could have in the world to try
to learn how to do things and so how can
we use that additional information in
order to serve speed reinforcement
learning so we're gonna do is talk about
some about imitation learning today and
then we're gonna start talking about
policy search and policy gradient
methods next week and those you can also
think of as another different way to
impose structure because in policy
gradient methods you always have to
define your policy class sometimes that
can be a really rich policy class and so
maybe that's not too much of a
limitation but other times you're
encoding domain knowledge by the class
you think that you represent okay and in
particular we're going to be thinking
about imitation learning and large state
spaces which is exactly the place where
you might hope to benefit from
additional help or supervision so if we
think about something like Montezuma's
Revenge
there's some nice work on looking at
sort of how far did DQ and get in this
case so montezuma's revenge for those of
you who haven't played it is sort of a
law very long horizon game in which
you're sort of trying to know
negate through this world and like pick
up keys and make decisions and it
involves a lot of different rooms so you
can see here what the outline is of the
all the white squares are basically
rooms and on the left-hand side sort of
a dqn that was trained for 50 million
frames only gets through the first two
rooms like it's just doing very badly
it's not making very much progress
whereas on the right hand side we see
something which is explicitly trying to
explore and it uses some of the
techniques that we'll be talking more
about later but notice that it still
doesn't get all the way through the game
and so I think this sort of illustrates
the fact that some of these games are
really hard
there has been some really nice
additional progress since both with me
and Percy Lange's lab we now can
basically sell Montezuma's and there's
also been some really nice work from
uber AI lab on solving
Montezuma's but a lot of the places that
people originally got traction on this
was by starting to use imitation
learning demonstrations so in particular
if we think about cases where RL might
work well RL works you know pretty well
when it's easy or certainly we've seen a
lot of success so far when data is cheap
and parallelization is easy and it can
be much harder to use the methods that
we've talked about so far when data is
expensive and when maybe failure is not
tolerable so if you try to use the
methods that we just described to learn
to fly like a remote-control helicopter
typically require a lot of helicopters
and because they're very hot I'll let it
be very expensive and so there's many
cases where this type of performance is
just not going to be practical so one of
the benefits is that if you can give the
agent a lot of rewards you can shape
behavior pretty quickly so one of the
challenges in montezuma's revenge is
that reward is very sparse you know the
agent has to try lots of different
things before it gets any signal of
whether it's doing the right thing and
where do these rewards come from I think
that's generally is actually a really
deep question but for right now let's
think about sort of that just even the
challenge of specifying rewards so if
you manually design them that might be
pretty brittle depending on the task and
an alternative is just to demonstrate
so if you had to write down the reward
function for driving a car it's quite
complicated like you don't want to hit
roads here hit the hit people you don't
want to drive off the road you want to
get to your destination and so it's very
complicated reward function to write
down but it's pretty easy for most of us
to just drive to a destination and show
an example of maybe an optimal behavior
so that's sort of the idea behind
learning from demonstrations there's
been lots and lots of work on this but
since people started thinking about
learning from demonstrations or
imitation learning I would argue
probably that this was started roughly
20 years ago around 1999-2000 was a
paper which started to think about
learning rewards from demonstration but
then there's been lots of applications
to it since so thinking about it for
things like highway driving or
navigation or parking lot navigation
there's a lot of these cases
particularly in driving right now but
where people have been thinking and
robotics to to think about how do you do
demonstrations of like how to pick up a
cup or things like that to try to teach
robots how to do those tasks there's
also some really interesting questions -
about like you know how do you do things
like path planning or goal in prints and
again these sort of cases where it's
quite complicated to write down a reward
function directly or it might be brittle
and the problem with brittle reward
functions is that your agent will
optimize to that and it may not be the
behavior that you wanted so the setting
from learning from demonstrations and
and today I'm going to be somewhat
informal about whether I call things
learning from demonstrations um there's
also inverse RL there's also imitation
learning
and there are sort of differences but a
lot of these things are somewhat
interchangeable most of this is about
the idea of saying that you have some
demonstration data and then you're going
to use it in order to help either
bootstrap or completely learn a new
policy so the idea is that you might get
an expert and maybe they're a perfect
expert or maybe they're a pretty good
expert to provide some demonstration
trajectories of taking actions in States
and in many cases it'll be easier for
people to do this but it's useful to
think about what it's easier to specify
one or the other and what situations are
common for each so what's the problem
set up the problem set up is that we
have this state space and action space
some transition model that is typically
unknown no reward function and instead
sort of a set of teachers demonstrations
from some particular we assume for now
optimal policy and a behavior cloning
we're gonna say how do we directly learn
the teachers policy so how do we match
try to how do we get sort of an
approximation of pi star directly from
this demonstrations inverse RL is
typically about saying how can we
recover the reward function once we have
the reward function then we can use it
computer policy and that often that last
step often is combined with emprender
ship learning so that we were both
trying to get that reward function and
then actually generated a good policy
with that in some cases you might just
want the reward function can I might
think of a case where you might be
interested in just the reward function
maybe you don't want to recover the
policy but you're just curious about
what the reward function is of another
agent yeah this is I think is a great
example so in a lot of science you know
biology excetera you often want to
understand the behavior of organisms or
animals or things like that and so if
you can just look at their behavior you
could say Trank monkeys or things like
that and then use that to back solve
like what is their reward function what
are the goals or preferences
I think there's a number of cases where
that's useful it may be down the line
you know maybe there's some optimization
that'll happen but but generally often
there it's just about understanding like
what is the goal structure or what is
the preference structure of the organism
or individual I could happen with people
to that you might want to understand
like the choices people are making in
terms of you know
commuting or in terms of buying
preferences or things like that maybe
later you want to optimize for that but
also you're just curious about how how
do people's behavior reveal the sort of
an underlying reward structure
underlying preference model yeah
demonstrations set like an upper bound I
guess were have there been cases such
that yes the like agent learns to
perform better than the extra did like
we find a new posture yeah as the nice
question of like is the experts behavior
an upper bound or their case is also
where the agent can go beyond this we're
not going to talk too much about this
today but there's a lot of work right
now on combining imitation learning with
RL so there's a lot of work on say like
inverse RL plus RL where for example you
might use this to scoot strap the system
and then your agent would continue to
learn on top of this there's also some
nice work from Peter Beals group where
they looked at assuming that the expert
was providing like a noisy demonstration
of an optimal path and said the goal is
to learn the optimal path not the noisy
demonstration of it so often you do want
to go beyond the expert there's
limitations to that and we'll talk about
that in a second actually of what what
are some of the limitations that you
might have if you don't get to continue
to gather data in the new environment
okay so let's start with behavioral
cloning which is probably the simplest
one because essentially in behavioral
cloning we're just going to treat this
as a standard supervised learning
problem so we're gonna fix the policy
class which means sort of some way to
represent our mapping from States to
actions and this could be a deep neural
network it could be a decision tree it
could be lots of different things and
then we're just going to estimate a
policy from the training examples so
we're just gonna say we saw these times
we saw a state in an action from our
expert and that's just our input output
for our supervised learning model and
we're just going to learn a mapping for
States to actions and early on so this
has been around really for quite a long
time and I should have said more like 30
years there was some nice examples of
doing this so Alban was a very early
paper
I insist him about thinking about
driving down the road seen a neural
networking and was trained at least in
part using behavioral cloning or
supervised learning to imitate
trajectories okay so let's think about
why this might go wrong and - first
let's think about what happens in
supervised learning so in supervised
learning we're gonna assume iid pairs Si
and we're gonna ignore the temporal
structure so we're gonna if we're just
droids supervised learning in general we
just imagine that we have these state
action pairs and then maybe we learn
some classifier or yeah let's just say a
classifier to classify what action you
know we should do and it might have some
sort of errors it might have errors of
will you know with probability epsilon
and so if we were thinking about doing
this over the course of t time steps
then we might have you know sort of an
expected total number of errors of
epsilon times t so let's just take a
second think about what goes wrong when
we're doing this in the supervised
learning or in the in the RL context so
by the RL context i mean the fact that
the decisions that we make influenced
the next state so let's just take like
one minute maybe talk to you your
neighbor and say like what do you think
could be the problem with behavioral
quoting in these sorts of scenarios and
if that's a simple thing to think about
then maybe think about how you would
address it so what you might do in that
case if there is problems that happen
when we try to apply standard supervised
learning to this case where it's really
underlying an MDP
[Music]
all right so first of all let's just
make a guess I'm gonna ask you guys
whether you think the the total expected
errors if we're doing this in in where
the underlying world is an MDP is gonna
be greater than or less than the number
of errors that we'd expect according to
a supervised learning approach so who
thinks that we're gonna have greater
expected total errors okay who thinks
we're gonna have less who many people
must be confused okay so how about so
many who thinks the answers that we're
gonna have greater maybe somebody who
thinks that's the case could say why
they think we might have more errors if
the real world is MDP and we've tried to
do the supervised learning technique
yeah an imprecise idea is that kind of
like as a human you're planning a more
long term horizon or like she's doing
one step and you know how that action is
gonna then give you like another
sequence but since we just start taking
a state in action and then like
predicting right from there we can't
plan that long-term sequence so it's
gonna like compound our errors as we go
that's right since it is correct we will
compound those errors and one of the
challenging aspects of this is that the
errors can compound a lot and this is
because the distribution of states that
you get can depend
the actions that you take so if you
think about this like a navigation case
like if I was supposed to go out the
right-hand door and I watched and go out
this door and I saw that he went right
and I and I you know tried to learn a
supervised learning classifier for what
I should do here
my supervisor learner was a little bit
broken and so instead of going right
here
I actually went left well now I'm in
part of the room which I never went to
because he was going over there to go to
the door and so like now I have no idea
what to do here like now I'm in the the
state distribution is something that I
haven't seen before
it's very likely that I'm gonna make an
error in fact my probability of error
now may not be my probability of error
here it's under assuming the fact that
the data that you get in the future is
the same distribution as the data you
got in the past our supervised learning
guarantees generally say when we have
them that I if if your data is comes
from an iid distribution then in the
future this is what your test error will
be the problem is is that in
reinforcement learning and Markov
decision processes your actions to
determine what is the data you're gonna
see so the fact that instead of
following the right action here I went
over here and now I have no data and my
data distribution is different so now
there's no guarantees for my super bill
it buys learning algorithm because my
date is different it's never been
trained on anything like that so it
can't generalize so that's exactly the
problem and this was noted by like drew
bag Mouse group from CMU in 2011 of
arguing that you know this is a really
big problem for what's called behavioral
cloning so even though there'd been some
nice empirical demonstrations of it he
and his former students Stephan Ross
indicated why this might fundamentally
be a very big problem and so let's
demonstrate some things that people had
sometimes seen empirically the idea is
that as soon as you deviate so this is
the time where you make your mistake
then essentially the whole rest of the
trajectory might all be errors you might
make team or team or errors and so that
means that the total number of errors
that you make is not expect it epsilon
times T but is epsilon times T squared
it's much worse and it's really due to
these compounding errors leading to you
to a place where your distribution of
states
very different than what you have data
about and this issue you will come up
again again the sort of a quote this
thinking about what is the distribution
of states that you get under you know
the policy you're following versus the
policy that you want to follow that
issue comes up again again in
reinforcement learning so it really is
this or foundational issue they you know
what is the data distribution you're
gonna get under the policy that you've
learned versus the true policy and
looking at this mismatch so once you go
off the race course you're not gonna
have any data about that so one of the
ideas that drew back Dowell and his
students came up with to think about
this was to say well what if we could
get more data so what if when I you know
my I only able in Mal data to start with
I've learned my supervised learning
policy to say you know what should I do
in each date as long as I make a mistake
so sometimes you know I I go out that
way my race car drives off the
racecourse what if I could know what to
do in that in that state so I reached a
state that I don't have any data about
what if I could ask my expert hey what
should I do now so like I go over here
I'm like oh my god I don't know you know
what to do now and then you ask your
expert in there like oh just turn right
it's fine you could still get out of the
right door it's okay so if you could ask
your expert for labels
well now you're getting labels about
states that you are encountering and as
long as all the as long as you have data
that covers all the states that you're
going to potentially experience the near
then you're supervised learning should
do pretty well this but the bigger issue
tends to come up with the fact that
you're encountering states that you
don't have any coverage of your training
data so the idea of dagger which serve
data set aggregation is essentially you
just keep growing your data set so what
happens in this case is you start off
you don't have any data you initialize
your policy you follow your policy so in
this case we're gonna assume that you
have an expert some expert policy so
that might be you know an expert is
taking some steps and then also your
other policy you could you collect a
trajectory so sometimes you're following
one policy sentence you're not and and
then what you get is you get this state
eight you get to go ask your expert for
every single state what would you have
done here so yeah for every state that
you encountered in that trajectory and
then you add all of those tuples to your
data set and you train your supervised
learning policy on that so everything
inside of your data set that you're
using to train your policy on is with an
expert label and you're slowly growing
the size of that data set so the idea is
you're sort of giving more and more
experts more more labels of expert
actions across the the directions you've
actually seemed and there's nice formal
properties for this so you can be
guaranteed that you will converge to a
good policy by following this under the
induced state distribution yeah just to
confirm this is assuming we have my
start of our falls what are we doing in
case we don't have the experts yeah this
is a great question so I when I was
looking that's just I would have to
double check I think this is assuming
your expert can give you the action
there it doesn't know assume that you
have explicit access to PI star because
if you had explicit access to PI star
you wouldn't need to learn anything so I
think in this case it's like tossing a
coin about whether the expert just
directly gives you the action in that
case or whether you follow the other
policy which because you have to have
the expert around all the time anyway
because they're always gonna have to
eventually tell you what they would have
done there okay that's how you get
excuse me that data set so that's
and I'm curious about how this is done
efficiently I'm I can imagine that for
some situations having a person sent the
command line well your your CPU trains
and inputs actions won't be efficient
how do people generally do this in such
a way that doesn't require manual
intervention yeah there's a great one
which is you know well this requires you
have an expert either around for every
single step or like at the energy
structure that can go back and label
everything and that's incredibly
expensive and you if you're doing this
for you know millions and millions of
time steps that's completely intractable
I think that's why I'm this this line of
research has been less influential in
certain ways than some of the other
techniques that we're going to see next
in terms of how you do sort of inverse
RL a so what this is really assuming is
that you have this human loop that's
really in the loop as opposed to just
asking them to provide demonstrations
once and then your algorithm goes off
and I think that practically in most
cases it's much more realistic to say
you know drive the car around the block
10 times but then you can leave and
we'll do all of our RL versus saying I
need you to be in the car or you know
like label all of the trajectories that
the car is doing and keep telling you
whether it's right or wrong I think this
is just very label intensive it's very
expensive so I think that in some
limited cases like if your action rate
is very slow like if your action rate is
you know making decisions in the
military or no others with very high
level very sparse decisions this can be
very reasonable because you could
basically throw you know infinite
compute at it before between each
decision making if you're doing this
first real-time hurts level decisions I
think that's very hard just be
compatible with like an expert taking
over the system right like it's somebody
sitting behind a wheel letting an agent
drive and then all like recognizing that
there's an emergency situation coming up
with taking the wheel yeah so like so is
this compatible with an expert taking
over yes I mean I think and that might
be an easier way to get labels so you
might say if you have an expert there
every action that's taken that's the
same as the action the expert would take
maybe they don't intervene otherwise
they only provide labels
or interventions when it would differ
but it still requires like an expert to
be monitoring which is often still
mentally challenging essentially you
know it's still high cost all right so
that that is a nice I mean there it's
very nice to see sort of their formal
characterization of why behavior cloning
can be bad and what is the reason for
this and I think that dagger is it can
be very useful in certain circumstances
but there's a lot of cases where just
practically it's much easier to get
example demonstrations and then assume
that there's no longer a human in the
loop
all right so inverse RL is more of one
of the the second categories so what
does what happens in inverse RL well
first let's just think about you know
feature based reward function so well
okay we'll get to there in a second so
again we're thinking about this case
where we have some transition model that
we might not observe or maybe we do and
a lot of the techniques here to start
with they did assume that you knew the
transition model that's pretty strong
for a lot of real world domains but in
some cases that's reasonable so for
right now we're going to assume that the
only thing that we don't know is the
reward function there's some extensions
to when you don't know the transition
models you okay so then we have again
our set of demonstrations and the goal
now is not to directly learn policy but
just to infer the reward function so if
I don't tell you anything about the
optimality of the teachers policy what
can be inferred about their overt
function I could say like it's not an
expert it's just demonstrations if you
get a demonstration of a state action
state etc can you infer anything about R
if you don't know anything about the
optimality
you
wouldn't be the same as sample so I
guess we get more demonstrations are
like our star I guess this is assuming
no assumptions about optimality so if I
don't tell you anything about the
optimality of the policy or seen it's
there any or any information you
couldn't gather in that case choices you
made under their policy just for that
particular person you could say
something about for their reward
function assuming that they're rational
agent that that that was higher in their
origin that's true but if you wanted it
to be about the general reward function
this would tell you maybe I'm staining
it so that it seems a little bit more
subtle than I mean it to be it doesn't
tell you anything right like if you if
you see me like wandering around like if
you see an agent flailing around right
and you know nothing about whether it's
making good decisions or not with
respect to the true reward function
demonstrations don't tell you anything
like they don't give you any information
about the reward function unless you
know something about unless you're
trying to make an assumption that the
agent is acting rationally with respect
to the true reward function and I may be
you can get some information about their
internal one like what saying but in
general if we don't make any assumptions
about agent behavior and we don't and we
don't assume that they're doing anything
optimal with respect to the global
reward function there's no information
you can get now the more challenging one
is the next so let's assume that the
teachers policy is optimal with respect
to the true global reward function which
the agent is also maybe gonna want to
optimize in the future so you get expert
driver per for a driver driving around
this is I think for a second about what
you can infer about the reward function
in this case and whether in particular
there's more than one reward function
that could explain their behavior so
think about what its unique so let's say
imagine data is no issue I give you ten
trillion examples of the agent following
the optimal policy 10 trillion examples
and you want to see if you could learn
what their word function is and that
question is is there a single reward
function that is consistent with their
data or there many maybe take a second
to talk to somebody around you I'm just
to see whether there's the question
really is there one reward function is
there a unique reward function if you
have infinite data so it's not a data
sparsity issue versus many
I'm gonna do a quick pull okay we're
gonna I'm gonna pull you guys that I'm
gonna ask whether you think there is one
reward function or if there's more than
one reward function so who thinks
there's a single reward function
infinite data singular award function
that's consistent do you think there's
more than one reward function okay can
someone give me a reward function that
is always consistent with any optimal
policy
I guess that what you need to do is in
the first step just if the older apart
that the teacher is going to have as a
policy then maybe on that first step
that you could may give the most the
reward that like they have a general
experience and then be random after that
so and I might depend on the state I
guess I was thinking of can only tell me
like a number which would allow or you
know a specification of a reward
function like a constant like a choice
of a constant which would make any
policy optimal yeah and the yellow you
just give a reward of zero for every
action you give a reward of zero any
policy is optimal respect that you never
get any reward anywhere it's a sad life
unfortunately and in this case all
policies are optimal right so so if you
just observe trajectories then one
reward function for which that policy is
optimal at zero but it's not unique so
this issue was observed I think it was
by Andrew Inge and Stuart Russell back
in 2000 where there is a paper talking
about inverse RL where they noted this
issue the problem is that this is not
unique without further assumptions there
are many reward functions that are
consistent so we have to we're gonna
have to think about how do we break ties
and how do we impose additional
structure yeah there are law so they
remember your name so yeah what that is
I think there's there's many many or
word functions so if you have a constant
everything has the same any constant
also the identical so there's generally
many different reward functions that
would all give you there are many
different reward functions for which any
policy is optimal and so that would mean
that if you're trying to infer what
function given some data
there are many award functions that you
could write down so that that data would
be optimal with respect to their award
function and that second part is really
what we're trying to get is we're trying
to sort of infer what reward function
would make this data look like it's
coming from an optimal policy if we
assume that the expert is optimal so
let's think about also how we do this in
in large state spaces so we're gonna
think about linear body function
approximator because again often the
places where we particularly need to be
sample efficient as when our state space
is huge and we're not gonna be able to
explore it efficiently so let's think
about linear value function approximator
and we're gonna think of this reward
also is been linear over the features so
our award function might be some weights
times some features representation of
our state space and the goal is to
compute a good set of weights given our
demonstration I already said that in
general this is not unique but we're
gonna try to figure out ways to do this
and different methods so the value
function for a policy PI can be
expressed as the follows following you
just write it down as the expected value
of the discounted sum of rewards and
this is the states that you would reach
under that policy under the distribution
of states that you get under this policy
these are the rewards so now what we're
gonna do is we express this so we're
doing now is this is going to be we're
having a linear representation of our
award function so we can write we can
re-express it like this so we can write
it down in terms of the features of the
state we reach on each time step times
the weight and then because the weight
vector is constant for everything you
can just move it out and then you get
this interesting expression which is you
basically just have this discounted sum
of the state features that you encounter
we're going to call that mu so we talked
about this very briefly earlier but now
we're talking about mu is being sort of
the discounted weighted frequency of
state features under a policy how
much time do you spend in different
features or you know basically how much
time do you spend in different states
for the future eyes version of that
discounted by kind of when you reach
those because some states you might
really reach really far in the future
versus now so it's really it's sort of
the stationary distributions we were
talking about before now we're using
discounting so why is this good okay so
what would what we're gonna say now is
that instead of thinking directly about
reward functions then we can start to
think about distributions of states and
think about sort of the probability of
reaching different distributions of
states different state distributions as
representing different different
policies essentially different policies
for a particular award function would
reach different distributions of states
and so we can think about using this
formulation for apprenticeship learning
so in this case we have this nice
setting for Brenda strip learning right
now we're using the linear value
function approximation we call it
apprenticeship learning we're learning
like the agents being apprenticeship
from from the from the demonstrator so
now we have this discounted weighted
frequency of the feature states so we're
always sort of moving into the feature
space of states now and then we want to
note the following so if we define what
is the value function for pi star that's
just equal to the expected discounted
summer rewards we reach and by
definition that is better than the value
for any other policy at least is good
because either pi is the same as pi it's
the same as the optimal policy or it's
different and this is just equal to the
same thing same reward function which we
don't know but under a different
distribution of states it's under the
distribution of states you'd get to if
you follow this alternative policy and
so if we think that the experts
demonstrations are from the optimal
policy in order to identify W it's
sufficient to find a W star such that if
you taught dot product that with the
distribution of states you got to under
the optimal policy
remember this is what we know these are
we can get this from our demonstrations
this has to look better than the
district than the same weight vector
times the distribution of states you'd
get to under any other policy any
questions about that so it's by making
this observation that the value of the
optimal policy is directly related to
the distribution of states you get under
it times this weight vector and that
value has to be higher than the value of
any other policy which is using that
same weight vector and just gives you a
different distribution of states like
the stationary distribution the
proportion escaped yes sizing me what's
the sort of a good way to think of it is
that should we think of it's or is like
a stationary distribution of states yeah
I think it's reasonable sort of think it
was essentially the stationary
distribution of states weighted with
this discount factor on top of it so
it's very similar to the stationary
distributions we saw before
all right so essentially it's the same
we want to find a reward function so
that the expert policy and the
distribution of states you reach under
it looks better when you compute the
value function compared to that same
weight vector under any other
distribution of states and so if we can
find a policy so that its distribution
of states matches the distribution of
states of our expert then we're going to
do pretty well so what this says here is
that if we have a policy so the
discounted distribution of states that
we reach under it is close to the
distribution of states that you got from
your demonstration so this is the expert
so if that's small
then your value function error will also
be small so for any W if you can if you
basically match features match feature
expected features or match distributions
of states then you're good then then you
found I found a value that's gonna have
a very similar value to the true so this
actually means for any WT here so it
means no matter what the true reward
function is if you can find a policy so
that your state features match then no
matter what the true reward function is
you know that you're gonna be close to
the true value yeah these would be used
to populate I guess an expectation what
your I guess values are safe right yeah
once you have and W you can combine that
with your muse to compute like a value
of the state right you can some overage
being able to use that to make decisions
when you're out of state so any the
question is about saying like okay so if
we're giving these w's or sort of what
are we solving for resolving for the
policy or resolving for W etc in this
case I think a reasonable way to think
about it is solving for W up and solving
for pi so what this is saying is that
lets say you're optimizing over PI if
you found a PI so right now we know the
transition model which is not always
true but if you know the transition
model for a given PI you can compute mu
because it's just following like you
could do Monte Carlo rollouts for
example so if you someone's given you a
PI and they tell you the transition
model you can roll that out and you can
estimate me a PI and it's saying that if
you do that so let's say I have some
policy I roll this out a bunch of times
I estimate my Mew and I check whether
that seems to be close to my mute my
demonstration policy if that's small
this is saying no matter what the real
reward function is you're gonna have the
same value as like what you're like like
you've matched the value that you would
get under the expert policy so you're
good you could
as father's edict
and I'm looking at the constraint on the
Infinity norm for W yeah and I don't
quite see where that comes from
I'm curious if I'm missing it here or we
haven't gone over it there's not why do
we have this constraint over W am i my I
would have to double check the details
to be careful about this but I'm pretty
sure it's there so that as we do these
backups and we do this approximation
that your errors are all bounded so that
things don't explode and that when you
do this proof that I think I'd have to
double check at this but but I think you
basically use holders inequality and
then you use the fact that the W is
bounded to ensure that your ultimate
value is bounded so in general you want
your your reward function to be bounded
and particularly the yeah in the even
with discounting like it's useful you
always need to make sure that you're a
bellman operator is like a contraction
to hope of good I mean we've already
talked about the fact that with linear
value function approximated you don't
always converge but if your rewards are
unbounded it gets worse yes trying to
fit this into other things I'm familiar
with is this basically like a maximum
likelihood way of looking at the policy
right like if we flipped a coin a
hundred times and we got 99 heads one
tails it's possible that came from a
fair point you know that we can't
discount that but it's unlikely right so
if we observe some expert agent doing
the same thing a hundred times that
could come from a rework function at
zero everywhere but not as likely as
some other reward function is that mean
like so is this sort of giving us some
way to deal with the fact that the
reward could be zero that we have the
sort of an identifiability problem this
is not handled that unfortunately so
this is still not guaranteeing that we
couldn't learn a wait that's zero
everywhere but what this is saying here
is that instead of thinking about trying
to learn the reward function directly if
you match expected state features
then that's another way to guarantee
that your policy is basically doing the
same thing to the expert so if you have
a policy that basically looks like that
visits the same states in exactly the
same frequency is what the expert does
then you've matched their policy and you
still don't necessarily know that the
double you've got is accurate or is a
good estimate of the reward function but
maybe you don't need it because if you
really just care about being able to
match the experts policy then you've
matched it because if you're if you
visit all the states with exactly the
same frequency as what the expert does
you have identical policies so it's sort
of giving up on it it's saying we still
don't know what the real reward function
is but doesn't matter because we've
uncovered the expert policy question
yeah so there's been a lot of work also
on doing this with deep neural networks
I'll give a couple pointers later to
sort of other approaches ok so this sort
of observation led to an algorithm for
learning the policy which is you try to
find some sort of reward function like
that means you know at W my choice of W
such that the teacher looks better than
everything else looks better than all
the other controllers you've got before
so it makes it look like sort of the
this W for this state distribution looks
better than W for all other
distributions and then you find the
optimal control policy for the current W
which can allow you to then get new Muse
because you have your transition model
here and you repeat this until sort of
the gap is sufficiently small now this
is not perfect if your expert policy is
suboptimal it's a little tricky how to
combine these I don't want to dwell too
much on this particular algorithm it is
not something most people use anymore
and people would use more deep learning
approaches but I think that the key
things to understand from this is sort
of this aspect of kind of if you match
state
but that's sufficient to say that the
policies are identical it's actually
that you're learning yes I remind me
your name Bruce Lee
is there any significance to use a
normal one versus any other normal thank
norm - ah good great question question
is why do we use norm 1 and equation 7
that is actually important it's not a
say the only choice but here this is
saying you have to match on all states
that's what the norm one is saying here
so you're gonna give em you pi is a
really bean of s I'm not showing that
explicit dependency here but it's of s
and so what norm 1 is saying is that
when you sum up all of those errors it
has to be 1 so you're really you're
evaluating the error over all of this
you could choose other things do it
change the analysis norm 1 and infinity
norm tend to be particularly easy to
reason about when you start to do when
you're trying to bound the error and the
value function okay so there's still
this ambiguity that we've talked about
so there's this sort of infinite number
of different award functions the
algorithm that we just talked about
doesn't solve that issue and so there's
been a lot of work on imitation learning
in anniversary enforcement learning and
2 of the key papers are as follows the
first one is called maximum entropy
inverse RL and the idea here was to say
we want kind of want to pick something
which has the maximum uncertainty given
that still respects the constraints of
the data that we have from our expert
saying we're really not sure what the
reward function is we may not really be
sure what the policy is let's try to
pick distributions that have maximum
entropy sort of make lease commitment is
there the opposite of what we're fitting
you kind of wonder like under fit as
much as possible and only make sure that
you match in these expected state
frequencies so both of these that both
of these methods and a lot of the
messages think very carefully about the
expected state frequencies you get and
comparing the the data you get versus
the data you have in the demonstrate its
demonstrator these type of methods can
be extended to where the transition
model is a node
often that requires access to a
simulator often it means so you could
imagine for the thing we had before if
you didn't have access to the transition
model but you did have access to act e
in the real world you could just try out
new policies see what your distribution
of states are like and how that matches
your expert demonstration and in fact
that's often what's done so maximum
entropy embrace RL has been hugely
influential and and then the second one
and this is also a note this is from
also from Zhu bag Nels group who is the
same person that came up with dagger so
that groups been thinking a lot about
and did a lot of nice contributions to
inverse RL and then in terms of
extending this to sort of much broader
function approximator x' Stefan Ron
who's here at Stanford extended this
using deep neural networks and again is
joined through this feature matching so
the idea in this case both of these
methods compared to sort of the dagger
work or assuming that you have a fixed
set of trajectories at the beginning and
then you're gonna do more things in the
future
in particular the general generative
adversarial inverse imitation learning
has these initial trajectories and then
it's going to allow the agent to go out
and gather more data so it can gather
more data it can compute the state
frequencies it can also use sort of a
discriminator to compare one of the
challenges is you know writing down the
form of MU can be hard when you have a
really really high dimensional state
space so writing down you know a
distribution of our images is hard so
what they do in this case they mostly
are focusing on Lu Joko style tasks like
robotic style tasks we'd have like a lot
of different joints but it's still hard
to write down you know nice
distributions over that so what they
focus on in this case is thinking about
things like a discriminator that could
tell between your expert demonstrations
and the demonstration and the
trajectories that are being generated by
an agent and so if you can tell the
difference between those then you're not
matching that's a that's a nice insight
as I say that we could use these sort of
discriminators Gans is a you know in the
discriminator function to try to figure
out how do we quantify what it means to
have the same state distribution and
really high
high-dimensional state spaces so this is
known as Gale and there's been a lot of
extensions to Gale as well earlier we
said that there could be real practical
benefits to learning the reward function
in certain situations it seems like the
takeaway though is that we can't
actually do that is that the correct
takeaway here um yeah so we're saying
well earlier is you're arguing that
maybe they work ties we really want the
reward function but maybe you're telling
us that we can't really do that I think
in this so we've mostly been talking
about like frequentist style statistics
when we're talking about statistical
methods here from that perspective it's
often very hard to uncover the word
function one thing that's often people
do when they want to say understand
animal behavior or things like that it's
you have a prior you can another way to
do this is you have a Bayesian prior or
award functions and then you do Bayesian
updating so they've given the data that
you see you try to refine your posterior
over other possible reward functions so
it avoids like then you could just not
have your prior cover that reward is
zero everywhere for example and so if
you have a structured prior that can be
one way to still use information to try
to reduce your uncertainty over peoples
or agents or animals reward functions so
see much you know what are what are
realistic priors for award functions um
it's a great question I think mostly it
depends on the domain that people do use
I think we'll talk a little bit about it
for the exploration aspects and people
do use priors over award functions for
exploration as well things like Thompson
sampling and require you to do that if
you want it to be as close to
frequentist as possible and often people
do Dursley distributions over
multinomial or things like that or
gaussians and i and so you'd use
conjugate
exponential families so everything's
conjugate but those aren't just a
realistic I think in in real domains the
benefit probably of using these sort of
priors would be to really encode domain
knowledge about you know whether people
are wrist sensitive what sort of rewards
you expect to be reasonable in these
cases
yeah when I think it to go back to point
two I think it a lot of it does depend
on what you want out
so if you really want to just understand
the reward function the preference
function then we need to maybe do
something Bayesian or we need to try to
have a methods can help us I cover it I
think what a lot of other methods ended
up saying is well maybe we care about
the reward function but mostly we just
care about getting high performance so
if we can uncover a policy that's
matching the expert policy we're fine
behavior cloning wasn't a good way to do
that because errors compound but now
there are these other ways that can do
that better and so we're fine with that
part and again I just want to emphasize
like Sergei Levine and others have done
work which really combines like you can
take Gail and and then go beyond that in
terms of it I exploration so you can end
up with a policy that's better than your
demonstrator which I think it's good
because often like if your demonstrator
comes from YouTube which is nice it's a
freely available place to get
demonstrations and you don't really know
the quality so often you might want to
use that does their bootstrap learning
but not necessarily be limited by it all
right
so just to summarize um you know in
practice there's been an enormous amount
of work on imitation learning
particularly in robotics but in lots of
domains and I think that you know if
you're gonna leave class today and go
out into industry the imitation learning
can be very useful practically because
often it's easier to get demonstrations
and it could really bootstrap learning a
complicated chari games etc but there's
still a lot of challenges that remain
particularly a lot of the domains that I
think about we don't know the optimal
policy so I think about healthcare or
like customers or education like
intelligent tutoring systems and all
those one of the big challenges that you
don't know the optimal policy and you're
maybe doing all this because you think
you could do something better than
what's in the existing data so that's
that's a big challenge and how do you
combine sort of inverse RL and then
maybe online RL in in a safe way so one
of the motivations I said for
limitation learning was oh well if you
want to be safe but then if your concern
say things right now don't do very well
then you have to figure out how to do
safe exploration in the future all right
I think that's everything for today
and I'll see you guys next week we're
going to start to talk about policy
search